على المستوى الثقافي هل في عولمه نعرف انه
ثقافه الغرب اصبحت الان موجوده في كثير من
الدول الاسيويه دول الشرقيه هل العولمه
يعني نراها اكثر مطبقه في السياق الثقافي
الاجتماعي عن التجاري
ندرس
لا توجد عولمه حقيقيه ما نراه لها من معنى
الان هو انه يتعين الابقاء على الصين
وروسيا عدوين اذا كان هناك منطق عدو فان
ذلك يفرغ هذه العباره بالمعناها لانه يقسم
العالم الى جزئين شرق وغرب يتصارعان دومه
وتدفعهما الرغبه لاختراق الزمات والتوترات
اخر الامثله عن ذلك عندما زارت رئيسه مجلس
النواب الامريكيه السابقه التايوان حتى
قبل ان يتخذ الامر بين الصين والتايوان
صبغه التوتر الحقيقي او حتى قبل ان تظهر
بوادر اشتباك
ودفعت زياره هذه السيده لتايوان الصين
لموقف قوي وعدائي اتجاه تايوان التي تجد
نفسها الان في وضع دفاع صعب فلستفزاز
قامت به الولايات المتحده لكونها تعرف ان
تايوان ستكون بحاجه للسلاح الذي تحصل
واشنطن من تجارته على اموال كثيره